Jesus as God omnipresent on Earth though
in his physical body human nature that
physical body was limited to time in
space yes while Jesus was on Earth as
God he was overseeing creation and aware
of all things but as a man in a physical
body that body could only be at one
place at one time let me prove it Mark
72 24-30
okay and read it for us good question
brother he says and from there he arose
and went away to the region of tire and
sight on and he entered a house and did
not want anyone to know yet he could not
be hidden but immediately a woman whose
little daughter had an unclean Spirit
heard of him and came and fell down at
his feet now the woman was a gentile a
syap phenician by birth and she begged
him to cast The Demon out of her
daughter and he said to her let the
children be fed first for it is not
right to take the children's bread and
throw it to the dogs but she answered
him yes Lord even or yet even the dogs
under the table will eat the children's
crumbs and he said to her for this
statement you may go your way the demon
has left your daughter and she how did
he come how did he how did he cast out
the demon from her daughter when he
wasn't there
physically yeah interesting did you
catch it and he did it right as she said
yeah for this statement goal the demon
has left your daughter oh man yeah wow
you caught it read 2 yeah well because
that yeah often times men they want to
try and use the defensive or like pivot
things to no no no that's that's
something that would be due to his
omniscience not his omnip no because
he's the one casting out the demon
because you came to him to cast out the
demon y oh wow so this would work too
with the Centurion uh soldiers oh yeah
that's another one you know that in
Matthew 8 yeah 5 to13 but I'm going to
give you another one I'll give you two
more okay okay but uh this one clear now
read Mark 7:29 again and then to 30
because watch and he said to her for
this statement you may go your way the
demon has left your daughter and she
went home and found the child lying in
bed the demon gone okay so she's coming
to him to cast out the demon he goes
I've already got rid of him go she's
okay so he doesn't have to be there
physically to summon demons out of
people because as God he's the one
sustaining creation sustaining demons
and without there being there physically
he can cast them out right yeah what
would you say to somebody who would say
well no that's his omnipotence that's
because he's all power okay but then
you're telling me he's exercising his
omnipotence without being physically
present so you're bearing yourself yeah
interesting good one yeah totally
because he's still doing something
without being there physically yep so
this is exactly like John one with
Nathaniel under the fig tree oh yeah
that well you got that one because he
says I saw you yeah not just I knew yeah
I saw I saw you so you can't just put
that aside to omniscience no I saw you
sitting under the F Tre that's since you
already know that one and the Centurion
let me give you one more John 4 because
this one is very strong John 4:43 to
54 okay it says after the two days he
departed from Galilee for Jesus himself
had testified that a prophet has no
honor in his own Hometown so when he
came to Galilee the galileans welcomed
him having seen all that he had done in
Jerusalem at The Feast for They too had
gone to the feast so he came again to
Cana in Galilee where had made the water
wine and at Capernaum there was an
official whose son was ill when this man
heard that Jesus had come to Judea come
from Judea to Galilee he went to him and
asked him to come down and heal his son
for he was at the point of death so
Jesus said to him unless you see signs
and wonders you will not believe the
official said to him sir come down
before my child dies Jesus said to him
go your son will live the man notice
he's coming to him for healing he says
go he's already alive he will live He's
not going to die now watch how long it
takes him to get back to a su this is
where it's going to get astonishing
verse
50 wher have you stopped keep contining
yeah Jesus said to him go your son will
live the man believed the word that
Jesus spoke to him and went on his way
as he was going down his servants met
him and told him that his son was
recovering so he asked them the hour
when he began to get better and they
said to him yes yesterday at the seventh
hour the fever left him the father knew
that was the hour when Jesus had said to
him your son will live and he himself
believed in all his household this was
now the second sign that Jesus did when
he had come from Judea to Galilee he
didn't arrive to his house till the next
day that's how far the distance between
Jesus and his son was did you catch it
no what verse right there when he just
said it was yesterday at yes yeah
yesterday at theeven hour oh wow wow
okay yeah he didn't arrive till the next
day yeah that's how far the distance was
and when they told him the hour he goes
that's the same hour the day before
Jesus told me he's well he
lives Jesus physically is not there the
distance so great it takes the father
almost a full day to arrive he only gets
there the next day but because he's God
he doesn't need to De physically as he's
talking to him he heals the boy you are
healed you will live go he's
okay yeah and he has to be present for
that to be possible yeah because he's
doing the healing so don't yeah yeah
yeah yeah because like isolated look
it's John 45-49 which is the Philip and
Nathaniel it's the Centurion Matthew 8
5-13 it's the syop phenician woman Mark
72430 and now this I mean how many more
examples do we need to show yeah that
Christ as God did not seize being
omnipresent